hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the long stephane to franchise has never
really caught on in the wet even though
there has been more than 20 titles in
the series this is set to change when
monster hunter world hits the shelves in
early 2018 if you are new to the Monster
Hunter franchise or like me you haven't
played in over a decade
then here's eleven reasons to be excited
about Monster Hunter World just in case
it wasn't obvious enough by the titles
you play as the Monster Hunter setting
out in a brave new world you take on
missions to discover unknown areas of
this new continent and venture through
quests to identify track and kill
hulking great monsters most of which are
based around dinosaurs dragons and
lizards if you don't want to kill the
beef you can trap it instead but come on
I didn't bring a 15 foot satya for no
reason
as you'd expect in 2017 the game
supports a full open world without load
screens dynamically changing from day to
night and vice versa surprisingly this
is the first monster hunter game to do
this in the past zones and areas broke
up the map allowing hunters to escape to
a new area when they were losing a fight
kind of like playing Resident Evil and
going through a door and leaving a
zombie on the other side in monster
hunter world you will need to know your
surroundings as there is no escape from
a raging engine act I think I said that
right we've seen a living breathing
ecosystem at work in the early footage
but what the heck does that even mean
trees can fall plants can be eaten snot
can be scraped from the wall but the
greatest thing about the ecosystem is
the natural food chain monsters will eat
monsters in fact we saw a great giraffe
eat and act enough and then scurried
back to its nest to regurgitate it for
the kids
brilliantly gross you can use the system
to your benefit - by leading monsters
you can't kill to a bigger monster - may
do the work for you now that's a living
breathing ecosystem once a monster is
defeated its carcass can be carved and
looted to craft equipment and weapons
strengthening your character in a
never-ending loop of
Conte killed loot as the difficulty
ramps up the yama steps and weapons you
choose will give you an advantage if
you've crafted the right set of course
saying that I do hope this sword wasn't
made from a monster junk there are a few
other mechanics new to monster hunter
world such as the Gili mantle which is
like a cloak which can increase stealth
allowing you to watch your prey in
close-up waiting for the right time to
attack different mantle help in
different ways there's a mantle for
luring a monster to you so if you wear
that one then I hope you run like Usain
Bolt another new item with multiple uses
is the slinger on your arm it's a
freaking grappling hook bringing
verticality in to fight allowing you to
swing high and even jump on a monster's
back if that's your jam if we don't want
to use it that way then just use it as a
slingshot instead hunters have Scout
flies to help them navigate and track in
different areas of the map pick up
enough monster evidence in this case
glowing snot piles and those Scout flies
will locate the Beast that sneeze
everywhere it will also work with
footprints and drool and other bodily
fluids let's get to the real selling
point for player cooperative hunt I
don't know about you but I would
absolutely love to track down monsters
with friends crafting different armor
sets to complement one another and
ultimately carving up a rathalos and
making it testicle into a new rucksack
you can build a squad before the hunt
begins using the hunting lodge loved by
so many players or if you've gone out
alone and you need desperate help then
fire and SOS flare into the sky opening
your game to others and hopefully
they'll come to your rescue structured
multiplayer drop in and out mechanics
and the server will be off into the
world - what mark would you want all 40
weapon types from previous Monster
Hunter titles a tier 2 so expect to see
some weird and wonderful sights
traditional swords and shields dual
blade big-ass dogs axes there's even a
bow if you prefer to stay at the
distance in a fight oh and look at this
one a gun Lance it's a freaking gun and
a jousting Lance all in wood what is not
to love there
this will be the first monster hunting
game on PlayStation since 2009 the first
ever on Xbox and the PC to expect the PC
community to mob the heck out of this
one and create Iron Man inspired armor
sets we don't have a fixed release date
yet but we are assured the release is
global and we can all play at the same
time using cross region cooperative play
except for PC who have to wait for some
reason most of underworld will be coming
towards in early 2018 what do you think
to it are you going to try out once the
hunter world excited I know I am and
I'll be working on my friends to get a
debate - I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade being a pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]